This is Radiolab. I'm Jad. Boom. Rod. My guest today is Robert Krulwich,
the science correspondent for ABC News, Nova and Nightline.
And we're talking about time,
the freezing of the speeding up of the slowing down of the absorbed science of
another politics of time.
Speaking of which,
my interview with member j Griffith from we heard in the previous whatever
section, she began her interview with me with a strange declaration,
which she read off a piece of paper.
This is the independent free state of troll. Haim,
we have no allegiance to the government. We do not recognize history,
patriarchy, matriarchy, politics, communist, fascist or lollipop men or ladies.
We have a hierarchy based on dog worship.
Our currency is to be based on the cog bata system.
We do not recognize the Gregorian calendar by doing so.
This Day shall be known as one. Be Afraid, be afraid,
all ie that here, respect this date.
What was that? That was the manifesto of um,
British anti road protests in the mid nineties.
The British and t road protest. Yes. [inaudible] like roads. Yes.
Environmentalist who are protesting against the building of roads.
And one of the things that they chose to do was to write this self-governing
manifesto,
pointing out that for them they were not going to recognize Greenwich. Meantime,
three hours, 44 minutes, I reckon they did universal time.
Time is a highly political subject.
It initially was the British sense of time,
which was transported all over the world.
Britain ruled their empire through ruling the oceans.
They rule the oceans because they discovered chronometer was of sufficient
accuracy to discover longitude.
What the British did in the empires was to insist on GMT,
Greenwich Meantime,
and you know all the countries where sort of Greenwich meantime retarded a bit
or advanced a bit,
but essentially all those will know him as the real slam in London.
I'm not sure what question is. The British don't own the seas anymore,
but we all still use Greenwich mean time. So lately, absolutely.
We're very used to thinking that empires are to do with land.
What I'm arguing is that actually though there have been empires of time
[inaudible],
but there's one story you tell about the rulers.
This is the ruler of trick menace than the current ruler of Turkmenistan.
A guy named President Niyazov.
Now the month of January in Turkmenistan is called Turkmenbashi and the month of
April is called Gerben Sultan. Why are they called that?
Well, he named one after himself and one off to his mother.
You mean everybody there sir in January calls it, you know,
president of our country month or whatever. Well,
I don't actually know whether you know that it's taken off in the street as it
were and I rather suspect it probably has. But what he wanted to do was,
what in fact many rulers have wanted to do is to ally themselves with the clock
and the calendar. I mean like poll pot decided that 1975 would be at year zero.
Paul Potts says, all right, everything starts with me. Yes, exactly.
Everything starts with me. Now when I say it does,
this is year zero and to you,
I guess the joy of time, the deepest,
most ecstatic version of it is when you lose it completely.
I think that's absolutely right. And I think that's something that, um,
you know, that in prayer, in meditation, in art, um,
and in love actually is that people lose that. Um, very,
um, you know,
fretful ticking off kind of sense of clock time and what you fall into,
um, is, is something transcendent. You know,
all that you have to have done is loved somebody to know that and to hold them
for half an hour.
And you can know that that half an hour has lasted an eternity time.
Standing still in a moment like that is like a,
a really swollen now. Yes, exactly,
exactly. And that in a sense, you know, that's when, um,
the moment meets the eternal th that that is all that matters is just this
moment that you're holding in your hand.
Thanks Robert. That was great.
Jay Griffiths is the author of a sideways look at time.
You can find out more about her on our website, radiolab.org.
We'll close our program today on time.
The way we started with an excerpt of performance is Beethoven's Ninth Symphony.
You know the one [inaudible] except this is not the way Beethoven would have
intended it to be formed.
The piece he wrote to last 70 minutes has been stretched to 24 hours.
24 hours. Yup. Bringing it even closer to eternity.
Recently a group of San Franciscans spent an entire weekend in a gallery in a
trance listening to all 24 hours and began on a Friday evening.
That is one oh two in the morning through the can went all night.
So it's about three 45 in the morning. Three 55 in the morning, in the morning.
Sound artist.
Aaron Zim was there otherwise known as the quiet American performance was at his
gallery. In fact, close our show today.
We asked him to give us a taste of what it sounded like. It starts with his
[inaudible] Duh, Duh Duh Duh Duh Duh Duh Duh.
But you know here it's like [inaudible].
Even though it's like a very simple thing to do to like say, okay,
it's not going to be 90 minutes. It's going to be a day. It,
it still gives you that sense of floating time or hanging time at a time that
uh,
it takes a long time to pass that you haven't certain places in your life where
major thing happens and evokes that
[inaudible]
you know how people report that uh, you,
your life flashes before your eyes in a car crash or something like that.
I'm seem to slow down for people as sick.
These really tense moments when if you happen to be playing Beethoven's ninth
symphony on like on your car stereo,
well you were going into some car crash or something.
Would it slow down and sound like this?
[inaudible]
the idea was to stretch something to 24 hours by stretching Beethoven's ninth I
don't only ratchet piece of music, stretch music history.
Oh God. Beethoven for 24 hours.
Just wondering if Beethoven is slowly spinning in his grave loafing. Yeah,
that's my name here in San Francisco this weekend. This is the second tool,
24 over performance upstairs where the performance is going on has a good five.
Everything seems very gentle.
If Laura is completely covered with beanbags or pillows,
the space has a really amazing acoustic sound system. He was really good.
What can I say designed to be contemplative? Why would I do this?
I have no idea why we're doing it. You will. I do it again. I don't know.
I want to see how I feel being exposed to a one unique piece.
Your first response was very calming response and then when I walked in and they
I can in after this I wanted to stretch, open up,
expand
[inaudible] [inaudible]
so I had this thought that different animals based on probably their size and
their heart rate might have different senses of time.
Like you see hummingbird zipping around in this manic way and you think we
humans must seem very slow to that hummingbird.
Everything we do must almost be in slow motion to something that can just deal
with things that quickly and to a whale or some huge animal with a heart rate
that just like once every few minutes, we must seem really fast.
This piece is kind of like that.
Suddenly I felt like I was moving at hummingbird speed.
No, I stretched out.
It's getting this money growing and growing and growing and you're just wanting
it to [inaudible] and it's not going to,
or it is rather,
it is climaxing but it's just taking place over such a long time.
That to us in our small human time, it doesn't feel like it's climaxing.
That's true. It doesn't feel that kind of climax never really happens.
That done in one. It's like euphoria. Right.
Most people. That's why, I don't know. Maybe somebody else ran out screaming.
I'm really serious. Oh, it's such an ecstatic apocalypse.
It felt
[inaudible] lifted up or just a constant lifting. Lifting. There was no,
just a constant lifting. Lifting.
[inaudible]
just got quiet. Yeah.
It sounded like it was supposed to go quiet there. Yeah,
it'll be a stretched out. Quiet. Yeah. It's probably just like a rest.
Yeah. However many times.
[inaudible] camps again,
that was produced by sound artist, Aaron Zim with help from Bronwyn's,
him and Jeremiah Moore. You can find more of Aaron's work on our website.
radiolab.org chat.
I was actually going to be the long a vowel and the odd mention sequence that I
was unable to make it to San Francisco. I guess we gotta get Outta here.
Yeah, we should close the show.
This week show was produced by myself and Ellen Horn.